demain matin au palais des congrès de
strasbourg un hommage sera rendu à jean
marie lehn par toute la communauté
scientifique
le prix nobel de chimie prononcera à
cette occasion le discours qu'il avait
tenu à stockholm il ya quelques jours et
faire trois as retransmettra demain en
direct de 10 heures à midi cet événement
juste avant à la bonne heure tout à fait
à cette occasion un voyage de presse un
voyage de presse a été organisée pour
des journalistes parisiens aujourd'hui
et demain dans la région thème de ce
voyage strasbourg deuxième pole de
recherche scientifique en france ce qui
va permettre aux journalistes de
découvrir l'état actuel de la recherche
en alsace et surtout ses perspectives
on en sait un petit peu plus là encore
avec philippe bêtes et gens huîtres 6
pourquoi les français ignore-t-il tout
ou presque des recherches scientifiques
menées en alsace
il aura fallu le prix nobel de jean
marie lehn pour révéler à certains la
qualité des laboratoires strasbourgeois
à l'évidence un manque d'information qui
est venu combler ce voyage sur mesure
pour 50 journalistes parisiens
parmi les équipements présentés le
visiteront ce bathyscaphe de la
recherche nucléaire en cours de montage
au centre de cronenbourg 50 mètres de
long c'est un tunnel d'acier ou se
libéreront bientôt d'énormes décharge
électrique
cet accélérateur de particules produira
pour la recherche des tensions
foudroyante 35 millions de volts
cette énergie phénoménale permettra de
comprendre les forces qui régissent
l'atome c'est bien sûr de la recherche
fondamentale mais les prolongements
industriels sont très prometteurs dans
l'électronique et les nouveaux matériaux
les chercheurs strasbourgeois ont conçu
un équipement tout à fait originale un
accélérateur qui peut émettre deux fois
plus de rayonnement
une théorie dont on comprendra en 1990
quand elle fonctionnera la vraie portée
scientifique